Off.
Ça y est ! On y est ! La relativité générale…
Vous avez sans doute entendu dire que ça
avait à voir avec la courbure de l’espace,
comme illustrée dans des images comme celles-ci.
Je trouve ces images absolument magnifiques,
car elles remettent en cause notre intuition
naïve de l’espace et du temps…
Et puis, surtout, il ne faut pas s’en cacher,
c’est grâce à de telles images, que la
relativité générale attire l’attention
et suscite l’imagination du grand public.
Et ça, c’est super important.
Mais ici, sur Science4All, j’aimerais qu’on
aille un petit peu plus loin, et que l’on
parle mieux de ce qu’il se passe vraiment
en relativité générale.
Après tout, c’est pour ça qu’il m’a
fallu 17 épisodes pour en arriver là où
on en est aujourd’hui.
Et donc…
Et donc il me faut vous dire que des images
comme celle-ci sont fondamentalement erronnées.
Pire, elles nous induisent en erreur.
Et donc, pour mieux comprendre la relativité
générale, il va falloir debunker ces images…
Mais avant de commencer, il faut que je vous
dise que la relativité générale est incroyablement
difficile à comprendre.
Du coup, aujourd’hui, on va devoir se contenter
d’une simplification extrême, très imprécise,
et encore assez compliquée.
Mais je peux vous le promettre.
Si vous regardez plusieurs fois les vidéos
qui nous ont amené à aujourd’hui, si vous
faites preuve de patience et de persévérance,
et si vous vous méditez longuement ce que
je m’apprête à dire, vous ne le regretterez
pas.
La théorie d’Einstein n’est pas qu’une
simple collection de faits.
C’est avant tout, je pense, la plus belle
théorie de la physique.
Donc j’espère que vous êtes excités et
motivés, car vous êtes sur le point de découvrir
quelques unes des idées les plus fantastiques
qui soient !
Off.
Pour commencer, il est utile de prendre le
temps de comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
des images comme celles-ci sont si erronnées.
Dans cette analogie, les objets semblent suivre
la courbure de la toile sur laquelle ils roulent.
Ça sonne bien.
Mais, réfléchissez-y.
Pourquoi semble-t-il que ces objets suivent
la courbure de la toile ? On a envie de dire
que c’est parce qu’ils tombent vers le
bas.
Mais pourquoi tomberaient-ils ? Serait-ce
à cause de la gravité ? Vous voyez le problème
? Ces images semblent expliquer la gravité
par la gravité.
C’est un raisonnement circulaire, et ça
c’est pas bon.
Alors, les plus malins d’entre vous diront
qu’il s’agit d’une représentation du
potentiel gravitationnel, un potentiel que
les objets peuvent descendre en gagnant de
la vitesse.
Et en effet, cette représentation est en
fait parfaitement cohérente avec la gravité
Newtonienne.
Mais elle ne correspond pas du tout à une
courbure de l’espace-temps que décrit la
relativité générale.
Off.
En fait, il est faux de dire que les trajectoires
décrites par les objets sur cette toile sont
des lignes droites.
En effet, ces trajectoires dépendent la vitesse
initiale que l’on impulse aux objets.
Or, de vraies lignes droites ne dépendent
pas de la vitesse à laquelle on les parcourt.
Souvenez-vous, une ligne droite, c’est ce
que l’on obtient si on cherche à garder
la direction de mouvement constante.
Et ça, c’est indépendant de la vitesse
à laquelle on essaie d’y arriver.
Off.
La raison profonde pour laquelle l’analogie
de la toile est très fausse est le fait qu’elle
représente un espace courbé.
Mais ce n’est pas l’espace qui est courbé.
C’est l’espace-temps qui est courbé.
Et ça, ça veut dire qu’il nous faut en
fait visualiser un espace-temps courbe de
dimension 4…
Oui.
Je sais.
Ça fait beaucoup d’informations en quelques
minutes seulement.
Disséquons un peu.
Qu’est-ce qu’un espace-temps de dimension
4 pour commencer ? J’avais introduit les
espaces de grandes dimensions en vous parlant
de la couleur de la lumière dans l’épisode
8.
En gros, un espace-temps de dimension 4 est
un ensemble de points qui peuvent être repérés
par 4 coordonnées, trois pour l’espace
et un pour le temps.
Et ce n’est pas si surprenant.
Pour prendre rendez-vous avec quelqu’un,
il vous faut et suffit ces trois coordonnées
de l’espace et du temps, pour que vos trajectoires
à travers l’espace-temps se rencontrent.
Mais je suis le premier à le reconnaître,
un espace-temps de dimension 4, ça fait mal
au crâne.
Je galère à me le représenter, et je suis
à peu près sûr que les experts de la relativité
galèrent à se représenter un tel espace-temps
eux aussi.
Pour naviguer dans l’espace-temps de dimension
4, on peut utiliser l’analogie d’un tissu
de dimension 2, comme le tissu dont on a parlé
dans l’épisode 9.
Mais ce doit être un tissu d’espace-temps.
Ce qui signifie que l’exemple de l’épisode
9 ne suffit pas.
Il faut que l’une des dimensions du tissu
représente le temps.
Et au fait, le temps passe.
Donc on est toujours en train de se déplacer
dans l’espace-temps.
On ne peut pas rester à un point donné de
l’espace-temps.
On est toujours en train de se déplacer à
travers le temps, et donc de suivre une trajectoire
dans l’espace-temps.
Alors, la théorie de la relativité générale
d’Einstein est une théorie de la gravité,
ce qui signifie que l’on va oublier, en
tout cas pour aujourd’hui, toutes les forces
non gravitationnelles.
Et comme la gravité n’est pas une force,
il n’y a donc aucune force en relativité
générale.
Il s’agit uniquement d’une théorie de
mouvements inertiels, c’est-à-dire sans
accélération.
Et ces mouvements inertiels correspondent
à des lignes droites dans l’espace-temps.
OK.
Donc tous les objets sont des trajectoires
de l’espace-temps, et ces trajectoires,
en relativité générale, sont toutes des
lignes droites.
Mais si l’espace-temps est courbé, qu’est-ce
que ça veut dire ? Alors, ça c’est une
question cruciale.
Et j’ai déjà longuement parlé de ces
lignes droites dans des espaces courbes
dans les épisodes 11 et 12.
Mais c’est un concept si important, que
je vais en donner une autre illustration maintenant.
Off.
Imaginons-nous en avion, volant tout droit,
et supposons que l’on voit un autre avion
s’éloigner de nous, en volant tout droit
lui aussi.
Parce que la géométrie de la Terre, qui
est la géométrie de la sphère, a une courbure
positive, petit à petit, après une longue
distance, la trajectoire de l’autre avion
va se rapprocher à nouveau de nous, alors
qu’il vole droit !
Off.
Il se passe une chose similaire en relativité
générale.
La grosse masse du Soleil va courber l’espace-temps
positivement, de sorte que la trajectoire
en ligne droite de la Terre va se rapprocher
de la trajectoire en ligne droite du Soleil.
Et c’est pour ça que la Terre reste proche
du Soleil.
C’est à cause de la courbure de l’espace-temps,
tout comme, en géométrie sphérique, la
courbure positive de l’espace a pour effet
de rapprocher les avions au fur et à mesure
de leurs vols en ligne droite.
Off.
Donc, pour récapituler, la Terre tourne autour
du Soleil, car le Soleil donne une courbure
positive à l’espace-temps autour de lui,
et car les lignes droites dans un espace-temps
à courbure positive tendent à se rapprocher.
La matière dit à l’espace-temps comment
se courber, et l’espace-temps dit à la
matière quelles sont les lignes droites à
suivre.
Vous avez compris ? Non ? OK, on va essayer
de voir les choses différemment.
Dans l’épisode 12, je vous ai dit que dans
un espace de courbure négative, l’espace
à un mètre de nous était, en un certain
sens, beaucoup plus grand qu’il ne le serait
dans un espace sans courbure.
À l’inverse, dans un espace-temps à courbure
positive, intuitivement, l’espace dans un
an sera bien plus petit que ce à quoi on
s’attendrait dans un espace-temps plat.
Off.
Une analogie que j’aime bien est celle de
la brioche au four.
Dans cette analogie, des raisins secs dans
la brioche représentent la matière, alors
que la brioche correspond à l’espace dans
lequel baigne la matière.
Quand la brioche cuit, l’espace entre les
raisins augmente, non pas parce que les raisins
se repoussent, mais parce que de l’espace
s’est créé entre les raisins.
Tournez le film à l’envers, et vous voyez
comment le dynamisme de l’espace au cours
du temps explique le rapprochement des raisins
sans faire appel à aucune force entre les
raisins.
En particulier, je vais maintenant pouvoir
adresser la question qui a taraudé nombre
d’entre vous suite à la vidéo précédente.
Souvenez-vous, je vous avais dit que le sol
accélère constamment vers le haut.
Or la Terre est ronde.
Donc si le sol s’éloigne partout vers l’extérieur
de la Terre, la Terre devrait grossir, non
? Voilà une excellente question !
La réponse est oui.
En un certain sens, la Terre s’agrandit
à travers l’espace, mais l’espace dans
lequel la Terre s’étend se contracte à
cause de la courbure positive de l’espace-temps.
Et c’est comme ça que la gravité permet
de maintenir les objets proches les uns des
autres.
Off.
Malheureusement, la vraie mathématique de
cette courbure est très abstraite et complexe.
C’est parce que la courbure de l’espace-temps
varie d’un point de l’espace-temps à
l’autre, et d’une direction à travers
l’espace-temps à l’autre.
Tout ceci ne peut pas être modélisé par
un seul nombre.
Au lieu de cela, il faut une combinaison de
plusieurs nombres, que l’on appelle un tenseur.
Comme le tenseur d’Einstein.
Off.
Le génie d’Einstein fut de relier mathématiquement
ce tenseur d’Einstein à la distribution
et au flot de l’énergie à travers l’espace-temps.
De la même manière que la courbure, cette
distribution et flot de l’énergie se doivent
d’être décrits par un tenseur, que l’on
appelle le tenseur stress-énergie.
En reliant le tenseur de courbure d’Einstein
et le tenseur stress-énergie, Einstein avait
déterminé la manière dont la matière impose
à l’espace-temps sa courbure.
Off.
Cette équation, appelée l’équation de
champ d’Einstein, est indiscutablement l’une
des plus belles équations de toute la physique.
Elle capture en une seule ligne l’incroyable
vision de la réalité par Einstein.
Une vision tellement plus subtile que ce que
n’importe lequel d’entre nous aurait pu
imaginer.
Mais une vision qui, enfin, fournit une explication
rigoureuse, élégante et complète à la
chute d’une pomme.